so much has been made about Jared Leto's
performance as the Joker as well as his
actions off screen you know the method
acting the gifts for his co-stars that
included a live rat and some bullets but
I wanted to investigate deeper into his
physical transformation and by
investigate I really mean just stalk his
Instagram feed we start 75 weeks ago
with this post look at those long
flowing locks beautiful isn't it
but what the hell is he doing with dr.
strange the big moment of truth Leto had
to part with his perfect ponytail I
believe those are director David Ayers
hands who also tweeted this photo
hopefully it was painless for now so
fresh and so clean Leto looks like a
completely different person after losing
the caveman beard and the long hair are
we sure this isn't a photo from the set
of Zoolander
this is definitely a different look from
where we started bleached blond short
hair and a white turtleneck who knew
this guy cleaned up so well no way this
is an uber right whoa that's a little
creepy mr. Leto here we see that Jared
got ahold of a razor and shaved his
eyebrows off completely
in fact it's rumored that he shaved his
entire body except for the top of his
head sorry
TMI is a [ __ ] of blue steel according to
his caption this is where the quote
transformation begins it's possible this
is just moments before he had his hair
colored green makeup slathered all onto
his face and those emo tattoos placed
all over his body
let us share this one just a week ago
there he is in full makeup and neon
green hair and if you look close enough
you can see the damaged tattoo on his
forehead David Ayer said the look was
inspired by drug lords on Instagram see
I'm not the only person spending
entirely way too much time on the ground
Leto shared this on set photo during an
iconic scene with dr. Harleen Quinzel
it's the beginning of their relationship
when she falls in love with the Joker
and transforms into Harley Quinn Margot
Robbie said the kissing scenes were a
total mess with all that makeup
in fact the makeup team needed an extra
10 minutes between takes just four
touch-ups let's scroll back 49 weeks ago
sorry guys
all good things must come to an end Leto
chopped off his bright green hair and
said his goodbyes in this very sad
Instagram post so what's the next look
for Leto one thing we know for sure he's
a man of many talents it's rumored he'll
appear in the upcoming Justice League
and that means I'll continue to stalk
his Instagram for more behind-the-scenes
shots of his transformation
you